the people behind the protests had been
called terrorists and hoodlums they
cause mayhem for the past three months
they're highly secretive because they
trust few and fear arrests we persuaded
this group to talk to us on condition
they remain anonymous they're educated
professionals and all have jobs
one's a health worker another's a civil
servant one has his own business and
there's a policeman son and this is
their basic protest kit fans for
anything pimping and this times is used
to craft a gas and put it back on very
early they're calling it the helmet
revolution no one has been involved in
violence before but they're ready for it
now they just called those brought with
them not standing with them just go -
todos vivo terrorists do you see
yourself as a terrorist no I'm just
normal civilian I'm educated I just want
to protect myself my home my family in
this place we use to use as a defense so
we can use these two bands of teargas
like this they also hide behind them
they carry saline solution including
your eyes when you get infected with the
Gerson and have tortures as well as
laser lights to try to blind the police
if you do the other night
so the kauffman when they're in the
field a cop they can really actually see
what behind the horn and they use
whistles to communicate with each other
and distract the police most of the
front line carry respirator masks -
operating clouds of tear gas these are
the weapons of Hong Kong's democracy war
I think this movement will go on even
they keep just arresting people because
you can arrest us all you can arrest all
2 million people that who came out to
but there's consternation at the violent
turn of events the use of petrol bombs
by protesters the outpouring of
vandalism and the pitch battles with the
police but there are repeated claims
about excessive police force and that's
fueling a lot of the protesters anger
now even this son of a policeman I know
that how they do like making fake
evidence you know being a sucks best not
criminal justice fest and what of all
the tactics they use to avoid the
cameras and just fractional the even
worst in gangsters they view this as a
war they can't afford to lose and the
government's decision to ditch the hated
extradition bill is not enough now you
prepare to get arrested for protesting
yes I already told my parents that if I
got arrested
it's why because we are all fighting for
our home we are even fighting not just
our home maybe their grandchildren's
home maybe their grand grandchildren so
it's not just about ourselves right now
this moment is about the future of Hong
Kong Hong Kong people are used to like
favorite peaceful protests but we have
now learned that peaceful protests are
useless people who used to think that
throwing breaks are so violent so it's
such a crazy thing to them but nowadays
is just the basics they're idealistic
warriors who insist they've been driven
to violence and know the outside world
is vital to we have to seek our help
from the international like at the
Americana like England somewhere else
we can't just win this revolution by
ourselves
so the plans plots and protests go on
Alex Crawford Sky News Hong Kong